hi my name is Alfredo quinones una cosa
I am an associate professor of
Neurosurgery Oncology cellular molecular
medicine in neuroscience at Johns
Hopkins University in the Department of
Neurosurgery and oncology I am delighted
to be here with you today and tell you a
little bit of my story about how I
became a physician scientist which is
what I did today
I show these three different pictures
just to illustrate some of my trajectory
when I was that small young child
growing up in Mexico as you can actually
see some of my friends have actually
teased me over time saying that I really
do have a big head and the reality is
that I had a big head all the way back
to when was I when I was a little boy
and he's not called hydrocephalus which
is the accumulation of water in the
brain
I just think that I was born with a big
head already and you can actually see
all the way from when I was about a year
and a half to about four or five years
all the way to just a few months before
I left Mexico when I was about 19 years
old and I came to this beautiful country
the United States I had an incredible
trajectory in my life wonderful role
models and it it all began in my house
the role model that I had as I would
rose I was growing up with my parents my
siblings in 1971 my little sister died
of diarrhea in a gastrointestinal
infection she was only 6 months old and
it was a major event in my life and at a
very young age and only the age of three
I began to realize that there is a
difference between life and death
such a young age and to think that these
sort of things could actually happen and
it still happened around the world it
may
we reflect very deeply into my role in
this world by 1979 my father told me
that I was an architect of my own
destiny
I paid very close attention to all the
things that my parents my grandparents
my siblings told me and right around
that time I began to realize that indeed
we do have things in this world that we
do for ourselves to some extent we are
the architects of our own destiny Santa
Monica had once said the chance in good
luck does not come to those who want it
he comes to those who look for it and I
kept looking for my own good luck all
the way since I was that little boy that
you saw with the big head by 1987 Mexico
had gone through a very difficult time
the economy was scrambling and I decided
to come to the United States immigrated
to the United States as a new illegal
undocumented alien to work in the San
Joaquin Valley as a migrant farm worker
my parents saw their first son leaving
the country I have to put it in
perspective because maybe about 15 years
prior
my mother had seen her own brother leave
the country never to return and never to
be found this is the place between
Mexico and the United States where I
actually hopped the fence we're looking
at it from the American side and this is
the exact place were back in 1987 I
looked and tried to find my own good
luck it reminds me of what Eleanor
Roosevelt said once no one can make us
feel inferior without our permission and
those early days were difficult I
deny that those early days of living
into this trailer which by the way I
paid $300 for it and a lot of my friends
now tell me that I was taking advantage
of not only was this a small little
house in the middle of nowhere that I
called my first mansion but the reality
is it the first night when I was living
in this mansion it started to rain and
that night I woke up completely wet from
water from everywhere and I took a
picture of this trailer as you can
actually see right here where I was
actually able to fix the roof very early
on not only was i working in the fields
of the San Joaquin Valley with his very
same hands but I was also already
beginning to fix things that were not
working how little did I know that this
very same hands were going to be one day
operating on brain tumors and doing
science to try to try to advance the
field of brain cancer I drove some of
the most sophisticated machine around
that time this is a particular cotton
picker and as you can see I was a full
life so full of energy and this is
actually a machine that always get me
excited to talk about it because right
here in the inside of this machine as
you can see you can actually sit not
much different than the way I see today
in my operating room chair just like an
astronaut chair and you're controlling
this big machine that is picking cotton
with both of your hands and both of your
fits very very early on I was having the
practice that was gonna allow me one day
to be able to do brain surgery
completely connected to my patients the
only difference nowadays is at the
microscope I also control it with my
mouth and I put a mouthpiece that I
control and just like back then I used
to drive this machine now I also control
the microscope with my mouth and I can
zoom
zoom out move the microscope from side
to side and be able to navigate the
brain back then I was navigating the
cotton fields now I've been privileged
to be given the opportunity but my
patients and their families to be able
to navigate the brain I was an
entrepreneur I took risks early on I
began my own trucking company this is a
truck that I bought and I had a dream
that one day I was gonna have a whole
fleet of trucks that was gonna allow me
to carry cotton from place to place some
of the products in the San Joaquin
Valley so early on I was getting all
ready there early teachings of taking
risk unfortunately things don't always
work the way you want it and as you can
see this truck I actually ended up
getting completely damaged not only
because I myself could actually fix the
engine that eventually completely blew
off because I didn't know much about
mechanics but I began to learn through
reading a book but the lessons that I
learned back then is never to give up
and always to try to try to push the
field forward and I push the field
forward with this little truck back then
by trying to fix it by trying to fix the
engine by trying to fix the ability of
this truck to work in the fields
eventually I actually ended up leaving
the field of the San Joaquin Valley I
was told once but one of my co-workers
thought I was gonna spend the rest of my
life working in the fields just like
many generations of Mexican Americans
who had immigrated to the San Joaquin
Valley I was going on 20 years or so
full of life so full of hope so full of
energy and to be told this is not
something that I was willing to accept
by the time I was in Berkeley I remember
I was given a cart by one of my
classmates with a court from Cesar
Chavez that said if you're not
frightened that you might fail you'll
never do the job if you are frightened
you will work like crazy in like crazy I
have worked my whole life not only as a
young child working in the
station of my parents but now as an
adult now as currently as a brain tumor
surgeon and as a scientist trying to
push the field in April 14 1989 just a
couple of years before I went to UC
Berkeley I had a major event in my life
in which I almost lost my life and I
remember waking up and seeing my father
after everything was under control and I
was out of danger he told me that I was
given a precious gift that life was
short just to be good to others this is
an early picture of me in the middle
with my brother Gabriel and one of my
co-workers in which I was working in
this railroad company in which I almost
left my life however I never gave up and
I never never was afraid of continuing
continuing to work really hard towards a
dream a dream that I was gonna make it
not only better for myself and my family
but potentially for future generations I
always tell my students that there is a
fine line between a being a mentor and
being a tormentor and I can personally
tell you that I proudly cross that line
my first mentor was Joe Martinez this is
a picture in 1993 in one of his
laboratory meters in his house I was
given the opportunity by dr. Martinez to
be part of science and since then my
life began he was an influential figure
in my life
this is 1994 by the time I graduated
from UC Berkeley with honors I ended up
following what my grandfather used to
tell me as a young child do not go where
the path may lead to go instead where
there is no path and leave a trail and
thanks to dr. Martinez I was inspired to
then pursue my medical education at
Harvard Medical School where I met two
other great mentors Dave Potter and Edie
Kravitz dr. Potter and dr. Kravitz were
not only role models but
people who believed that I could
actually make a difference in science
but I never forgot where I came from
this is a picture that I did with two of
my classmates miguel Canales and Reuben
Fragoso in which we have symbolisms of
the Aztec culture by the Sun in which
we're all moving upwards in our lives
but turning back in trying to help
others that are behind this is the
theory of life scatter Rita which is the
ladder the ladder to move upwards in our
society I strongly believe that
education is the best provision for old
age I was told once by the time I
graduated from Harvard Here I am in
Harvard Medical School given the
commencement speech chosen by my
classmates and I was reminded what Vince
Lombardi once said the quality of a
person's life is in direct proportion to
their commitment to excellence
regardless of the chosen field of
endeavor here I was now as a resident
being doctor by my own daughter outside
of the operating room
and in the operating room using some of
the most sophisticated equipment to be
able to perform brain surgery I pursue
research and you will learn more in my
next segment of brain tumors and stem
cells but I was able to work with
astrocytes stars that lie within the
brain that we believe our stem cells how
little that I'm that I know that that
little boy that work in this little gas
station at the age of five was one day
going to be surrounded by incredible
stars this is a picture a few day a few
years ago of the graduation of some of
my residents and to my right is that for
Alessandro O'Leary then if you look
further is dr. Henry Bram and then right
next to that for Henry Bram is one of
the greatest icons of the
african-american medicine which is dr.
ben Carson I've been surrounded by star
this is a picture of astrocytes that I
use in my research I get to do and use
the
sophisticated equipment in the upper
in-room because I believe that my role
as a physician and surgeon and scientist
is not only to give hope inside of the
operating room but also outside of the
operating room through our work the
brain I was told once is not a vessel to
be filled but a fire to be ignited we
have a high dropout rate by the year
2050 we're going to be one of the
largest groups Hispanic population of
this country one out of four people by
2050 would be a Hispanic descent if we
don't educate them we will not be able
to continue to sustain this beautiful
country so I believe that that through
the termination dedication discipline
resilience excitement admiration and
mentorship we can do great things
together
success Winston Churchill once said is
going from failure to failure without
the loss of enthusiasm I tell my own
children that sometimes we fall so we
can have an opportunity to get up and
try again I tell my own children the
lessons that I learned from my own
grandfather that a fool with a good tool
is still a fool that is not the tool
that matters but what you do with it
and your education is a tool and the
better you use it the better we will be
able to keep this country as beautiful
as it is today I am thankful for the
people that have surrounded me all these
young people that keep me energized in
vibrant and up-to-date not only in
science but also in education and
medicine and by continuing to give hope
to my patients I thank you for your
attention dr. quinones here from Johns
Hopkins
you